[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELYSE GUILFOYLE:
Today, I'm really
excited to be introducing a
podcast and a resource that
has done amazing work
in the criminal justice
space, "The Returning Citizen."
We're really lucky to have
the co-creators here--
Jacob Smith, Imani
Mixon, and Erik Burgess.
And they've put together
a really amazing group
of people that are going
to be discussing today
how we can empower
ex-offenders through education.
We have some
questions that we've
taken from Googlers in
advance, so we'll circle back
to those at the end.
But for now, I'm going to
kick it off over to Jacob.
Thank you.
JACOB SMITH: Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you everybody
for being here
and for everybody tuning in.
Welcome to a very
special edition
of "The Returning Citizen."
We are recording live here from
the brand-new Google Detroit
headquarters in the
Little Caesar's Arena.
Before we kick off, I just
want to give a huge shout-out
to Elyse Guilfoyle of
the Talks at Google team,
everybody at Google for all
of their incredible work
in bringing this to light.
This started as just
an idea, and here we
are actually doing it.
So that's pretty cool.
So without further ado,
let's dive right in.
So I'm Jacob Smith, a
Detroit-based entrepreneur
and social justice organizer.
IMANI MIXON: And
I'm Imani Mixon,
a Detroit-based
and embraced writer
who reports on
neighborhood change
and creative independence.
And we started "The Returning
Citizen" back in 2017 just
as an idea that you kick
around with a co-worker
after work and with
a friend that you
meet through that co-worker.
We're not at that
company anymore,
but we are getting
our ideas out anyway.
So "The Returning Citizen" is a
resource for returning citizens
and their families,
and we hope to just
bring a bit of positivity
to the enormous challenges
that they face.
And just for a quick
context, the US
has the most prisoners,
which is over 2 million,
and the highest per
capita incarceration
rate of any country on earth.
So that means that about 1 in
100 Americans are incarcerated.
And most of these folks will
return home as our neighbors.
We believe everybody wins
when we hope these returning
citizens become successful.
And if you like
what you hear today,
feel free to visit
www.thereturningcitizen.org.
We're also on SoundCloud
and other podcast platforms.
JACOB SMITH: Absolutely.
Thank you, Imani.
So just to explain what we're
talking about here today--
so when men and women
come out of prison,
it's safe to say that they face
a lot of different challenges.
And there's no
instruction manual.
You're not provided with
an instruction manual
when you come out that tells
you where to go, what to do,
how to thrive.
So what we're talking
about here today
is how arming yourself
with knowledge and skills
can really be the difference
maker in being successful when
transitioning out of prison.
So specifically,
how we can empower
ex-offenders or returning
citizens through education.
So yeah, let's go
ahead and dive right in
and meet our incredible
group of panelists here.
Aaron, you want to go
ahead and kick it off?
AARON KINZEL: Thank you, Google.
Thank you, Jacob.
My name is Aaron Kinzel.
I'm a professor of criminology
and criminal justice
at the University of
Michigan-Dearborn.
My areas of teaching expertise
following corrections
and public policy
and my research
is focused predominately
on prisoner education.
And the reason I'm very
passionate about prisoner
education is because it has been
the life-saving factor for me
because, as a young man, I
was incarcerated for about
a decade in the carceral state.
So I spent the ages of
18 to 28 incarcerated.
I took a college class just
towards the end of my sentence.
And when I came home, I started
an associate, bachelors,
masters, and I'm now finishing
up my doctorate and also
a faculty member
at the university.
So education can make people
thrive in the carceral state,
and I was also a very
serious and violent offender
who was transformed through
education in the system.
So I encourage all of
you to look at ways
that we can restore
post-secondary education
for people in the
carceral state.
MICHELLE SMART:
Hi, good afternoon.
I am Michelle Smart.
I am founder of
Bags to Butterflies.
We are a social enterprise
located in Detroit.
Our mission is to empower
formerly incarcerated women
with transitional employment,
resources, and a caring network
on their journey to success.
Our journey began in
2015 with a focus group
that consisted of 10 women
who served between five and 30
years in prison.
The barriers that they
shared that they face
was employment and housing.
Our organization is tackling
the employment barrier.
Thank you.
KARLOS L. HARRIS: And
I am Carlos Harris.
I served about 11 and 1/2 years.
My return to
Detroit, as we would
begin to surge with
the skilled trades
for the second chance
or the opportunities
for returning citizens
here in the city.
So I decided that I would move
here about three years ago
from Ann Arbor.
And so now, we own a
school in Southwest Detroit
called DSDT, Detroit School
for Digital Technology.
I own a digital
marketing agency.
The name of it is Koded Icons.
And we work with a number
of initiatives around town,
whether they be the
Michigan Works, DESC,
Department of Corrections,
and our main key, say,
is to try to change individuals
that are coming home
by training them with
technology skills
to get them gainfully employed.
ERIK BURGESS: Good
evening, everyone.
First of all, I'd like to
thank Google for this platform
for us sharing some valuable
information and the experiences
that we have endured.
I'd like to thank all the
attendees for taking time out
of their schedule for
attending this platform also.
My name is Erik Burgess.
I am co-creator of "The
Returning Citizen Podcast."
I did 18 years in prison
for a drug-lifer Law,
which, when I first
was sentenced in 1991,
I had mandatory life
without no parole.
So I'm taking this opportunity--
I feel obligated to make an
impact on the quality of life
for anyone who's
been incarcerated,
but my main focus and passion
is to be proactive and not
allow anyone to become
a returning citizen.
Thank you.
IMANI MIXON: Perfect.
Thank you all for
those introductions.
I think it's important to let
people tell you who they are.
So that was beautiful.
It's great to share
this space with you.
And yeah, just to get
the questions rolling,
I know my personal experience
with returning citizens,
like, in family,
when people get out,
they're trying to figure
out how to provide
basic needs for themselves.
And it seems like things
like education or employment
are sort of out of their grasp.
So in your experience,
what role does education
play for returning citizens
upon transitioning back
into society?
AARON KINZEL: So
employment and education
are pivotal to allow people
to return to their communities
safely and to become
productive citizens.
However, there are
a lot of barriers.
There is something called
the collateral consequences
of criminal conviction,
which basically
are legal sanctions
throughout the United States,
there's 40,000 of
them, that allow
you to legally discriminate
against someone like myself
or some of these other panelists
who have been convicted
of various types of felonies.
So checking the
box is one thing,
where you have to disclose on
a felony background for a job
applications.
Myself, coming home six years,
my first six years home,
I couldn't find
employment because I
kept checking that box.
Hundreds of applications,
no one would ever
give me an opportunity.
My first job was
actually a lecturer
at Western Michigan
University, where
I was offered a job,
which, to me, is just
kind of insane, where it took
me six years to find employment.
It's just really sad.
And education has been
shown to dramatically reduce
recidivism rates.
So, like, nationally, we
have recidivism rates now,
which are just
horrendous, if you
look at the Bureau of
Justice Statistics.
After a nine-year period
of people like ourselves
coming home, 83% of
us get rearrested
within that nine-year period.
So for those of us that have
been home nine years or more,
we're among the 17% that
have somehow beat those odds.
And it's not that a
lot of these people
are bad people or doing
really bad things.
They're just trying to survive.
And if you don't have education
and you don't have skills,
it's even harder for you to find
employment with those barriers.
So what are some
things that we can do?
Education, when put
in a carceral space,
dramatically reduces recidivism
rates by 43% on average.
So if we reinstated Pell Grants
to prisoners across the nation,
invested in more
programs where there were
post-secondary
programs, particularly
vocational skills, then
these people who are inside
are more prepared
when they come home
to become productive in whatever
community they end up going to.
And that's good
for the community
because people are not
committing more crimes.
MICHELLE SMART: So
at our organization,
we hire women immediately upon
returning to the community.
And we are taking
what we believe
is an innovative
approach to create jobs.
Our organization creates
handbags using repurposed wood.
And the women that we've
hired just recently
served 34 years in prison.
They're coming back
to a community--
it's like a whole new world.
Our environment is
a little different
in that the ladies
are encouraged to be
as creative as they like to be.
When they come in
for the interview,
they do have to be interviewed.
They are referred.
We have two women who
were referred by MDOC.
The other two were referred
through another organization.
They do go through
a formal interview.
But through the interview
process, they also sit down.
We sit down with them and
find out what they want to do.
From that day
forward, we're going
to encourage them to let
go of the past, live life
today, and focus
on their dreams.
So for us, educating them is--
one of the young ladies wanted
to go to driver's training.
She had been in prison 41 years.
We helped her go through
driver's training.
Another young lady wanted to
go to school to learn to sing.
That's her passion.
We wanted to help her
follow her dreams.
So we're taking kind of
a nontraditional approach
to educating the women
and also employing them.
KARLOS L. HARRIS:
And I love the fact
that she says "a
nontraditional approach."
So I, myself, in
serving 11 years,
I did it on what we call
"the installment plan"
I'm a C-prefix.
So that means I went to
prison three times, all right?
And it was mainly because
of the lack of education,
not that I'm an illiterate
person or I didn't know,
it's just that each
time that I got out I
didn't have those
mentors around me.
I didn't have anyone
around me to encourage
me to do somewhat better.
And it wasn't until I
came here to Detroit
and the opportunities that are
being afforded The Returning
Citizen population that I saw
that there was one for me.
And that was in technology.
About three years ago,
I decided that I wanted
to get into digital marketing.
And that wasn't something that
a returning citizen perhaps
could do.
And so I decided that, you
know, I would teach myself.
So thanks to Google
and YouTube, I
was able to literally sit
down and spend a lot of hours
to reprogram myself.
And I'm so passionate
about that now.
It's afforded me to be able
to go back into the Michigan
Department of Corrections
and share those opportunities
with guys who are
coming home and who
haven't the foggiest idea
of what the technology
landscape here is now.
I brought a friend
with me today.
His name is Mr.
Willie Lyles Bay.
He served 45 years.
45 years.
And he's an example of
the type of individuals
that we're working with
in order to give them
the skill sets to be able to
meet some of the employment
barriers that we're
having in our community.
ERIK BURGESS: Thank you.
I think education is very
pivotal, like he said,
for individuals who are
going through a transition
of coming home.
It'll afford you
more opportunities,
more marketable skills.
Like, when I was in prison, the
only thing we had was college.
There wasn't no type of skill or
trades where we can learn from.
So I say some of
that education was
based on antiquated
theories and something
that we couldn't apply
when we come home.
So basically, what component we
had to have was the attitude.
So we had the attitude
to change and pursue
other avenues of being
successful out here.
Like I said, I'm in
school now at Wayne State,
taking up psychology, and I'll
be graduating in the spring.
So that's one way I'm trying
to make myself more marketable.
I'm in the process of becoming
a social entrepreneur,
where I can have an
impact on quality of life.
JACOB SMITH: Great.
And so, Aaron, you touched
on this just briefly,
and I've talked about it
with a number of people
on this panel in the past.
But educational
opportunities in terms
of while you're in prison,
what types of options exist?
You mentioned bringing back
Pell Grants, for example.
Erik, I know we've talked
a lot about your GIS
training and the self-education
that you were doing
with technology magazines.
Could you guys speak to
while you are incarcerated
what types of opportunities
are available if somebody
is proactive if they
want to be taking
that power into their
own hands as it currently
stands in Michigan but
more broadly speaking?
ERIK BURGESS: Michigan, firstly,
the most basic education
to have, unfortunately, is
a GED, a General Education
Diploma, which, at least, I
think 40% of prison population
do not have a GED,
unfortunately--
a lack of education as
Carlos had reiterated.
That's one reason
why the incarceration
rates are going up.
I changed my attitude.
Like Carlos said, I
wasn't illiterate.
I wasn't dumb.
I changed my attitude because
I wanted to prepare myself,
and I had a plan for
when I come home.
So I became a GED tutor--
and once the opportunity
came up to learn GIS
because I know that's
the way the landscape
and the format of the
world was going to.
I wanted to have some
type of knowledge
where I can be more marketable,
have some type of skills
to advance myself.
And [INAUDIBLE] doesn't
make my family proud.
That's what I wanted to
do-- make my family proud.
Because they're also going
through an incarceration period
too, also.
And some individuals
do not understand
how it's a very burden
on your family as well.
So if you have family
in your corner,
I think we're obligated,
not only to ourselves,
to our family, we're also
obligated to our community.
And I think we're the epitome
and the apex of what attitude
can do as far as
changing your life
and changing your thoughts.
That's all it is.
JACOB SMITH: When does
the teacher appear?
ERIK BURGESS: When does
The teacher appears when
the student is ready.
And I stay ready.
AARON KINZEL: So I think the
predominant form of education
in all carceral
spaces, whether that's
Michigan, or anywhere in the
US, or the federal systems
is informal education.
And that was extremely
powerful for me
because when I went
into the system,
I was a high school
dropout, 18-year-old kid.
I ended up taking my
GED in the county jail
when I was awaiting trial.
So that was like my
first little piece.
So a lot of institutions
do have GED,
which I think is a great
step in the right direction
to help with those basic skills
with literacy, math, et cetera,
but there's very few
college programs anymore.
So in 1994, the
Omnibus Crime Bill
passed under the
Clinton administration,
which destroyed Pell Grant
eligibility for prisoners
nationwide.
And in my personal and
professional opinion,
this was the most
devastating piece
of public policy that has ever
crossed a congressional space.
It destroyed college
education nationwide.
And fast forward
now, we're in 2018.
There's very few educational
opportunities that
are post-secondary in nature.
However, in Michigan, we
do have a Pell Grant pilot,
which was sponsored by the
US Department of Education
under the Obama administration.
And Michigan does have several
sites in which prisoners
are gaining Pell Grants
and actually earning
associate's and bachelor's
degrees right now, which
I think is extremely powerful.
And again, there's
research to back it up,
where recidivism rates go down,
but also just anecdotally,
anyone that I know that's
had some type education
in the system is employed.
They have a better grasp on
their family connections.
They're civically
engaged citizens.
There's so many things
that they're improving upon
because they become educated
and become civically engaged.
And that makes them more
likely to stay out in society
and be productive and
taxpayers citizens.
There's such a tax
base that we're
losing by really
disenfranchising
people that have been
locked up in the system.
And we're losing economic
growth as a nation.
And there's so much of
this technology stuff.
And with Google here, I
think that's the future.
If we can think about ways
to integrate more technology
in the prison space and for
people coming home, too,
who may lack the skills--
like, when I came
home, the new hotness
was those Motorola razor
flip phones in 2007.
I don't know if any of you
remember those, but like,
this texting was
like, holy shit.
Like, oh my god.
Like, we can text.
And now, we all got
our smartphones that
can do just about anything.
And for someone that's been
down 10, 20, or 30 years,
that's just like being like
dropped into Shangri-La
and you have no idea what to do.
So I really congratulate you,
Carlos, for helping people out
on that because that's
a much-needed piece
of re-education in
those populations.
KARLOS L. HARRIS: So
part of my process--
so I have some college.
I'm a college dropout.
I was going to school for
business computer science.
And I can remember one of
the last professors I had.
He told me I didn't know the
difference between there,
their, and they're;
to, too, and two.
So one of the first
things that I accomplished
while incarcerated was
I began to read as much
as I could get my hands on.
Because I wanted to know.
And it was through
that reading--
you know, everybody in prison
says I'm writing my book,
right?
So I was able to write for
novels that when I came home
I self-published.
And it was through
that trajectory
that I landed myself
at a point to saying
that I can do something
other than the crime that
was taking me to prison.
You know, so many
of the guys that I
come into contact with now--
I say it like this.
I'm really blessed.
Because after having
served the time,
I'm able now to go
back into the prisons
to meet these
gentlemen and women.
And prison wasn't like
that when I came through.
We didn't have the
opportunities, right?
So Aaron speaks about
the Pell Grant initiative
that MDOC had a few years ago.
Well, because of the
Second Chance grant,
we actually have a contract
with MDOC in which we go in
and we train--
I think it's 119 individuals
that's allocated to a program
that we have in technology--
information technology.
And so the research is that
we would train them inside.
And once they return back
here to Wayne County,
we actually are getting
them a place in employment
opportunities that otherwise
they wouldn't have access to,
you know?
And that's through
the Labor Department.
That wasn't there when I
came through the department.
And I think that the more we
have conversations like this
and we have those innovators
like a Mr. Burgess
that are futured or forward
thinking in their approach,
the more we can begin to
help more of our community
that are returning home.
You have guys that spent 40
years that literally do not
have the skill sets to
send a simple email.
That's something we
take for granted.
And I promise you, it's
painful to see a person
stand at a computer and tell
you they can't turn it on.
So that's one of the
biggest things I and my team
are trying to dismantle
across the department.
We're mainly in Michigan
now because that's
kind of like a foothold for us.
And it's to make sure that
those that are returning back
to our communities at
least have some technology
savvy about themselves to
where they can simply fill out
these online applications and
have access to the employment
opportunities that we all
just take for granted.
IMANI MIXON: Thank you.
And it sounds like you all
sort of found your own ways
to educate yourself
and go on a journey
after transitioning out.
But we know hindsight is 20/20.
So what do you wish
you knew upon re-entry?
Anybody?
KARLOS L. HARRIS: I
wish someone had really
told me about your network
determines your net worth.
You know, my grandmother
used to always say--
I'm from Arkansas.
I'm sorry.
So my grandmother used to always
say, birds of a feather flock
together.
And that's so true.
Now that I'm older--
I'll be 46 next month.
And I've learned in my older
age now that the people that I
really associate
with, they kind of
have an influence
on my future, right?
One of the first clients
that I got when I became--
I opened my digital marketing
agency was a judge that
sits over at 36 district now.
He called me to his
office because he
heard about this returning
citizen that does websites.
And so he called me over,
and here I am in his chamber.
And I'm thinking,
wow, I'm literally
in the back room with a judge.
If not for technology,
if not for me
seeing an opportunity
for me in this space,
I would've never had that
opportunity, you know?
Because the crimes
that I committed--
I did burglary.
And whenever I sat
and, I did the résumés,
I would always be told
that I couldn't get the job
because they were
crimes of dishonesty.
So technically, I wasn't
about to get a job pretty much
anywhere.
So I had to be creative
in my approach.
And I just wish someone
had sat and told me many,
many years ago to really
start to position myself
with a network of individuals
that could actually
shift my mindset into
a better direction
to where I wanted to go.
Because I like to think I
never was really a bad person.
I think we all probably
would say that.
But at the same time, had I been
with more like-minded people,
the travel wouldn't have been
as long as it has been for me.
ERIK BURGESS: The one thing I
wish I knew is how to listen--
is how to listen.
We learn that when
we're younger--
just how to listen.
You have to know how
to listen to learn,
and so that's one thing I wish--
I didn't listen.
And signs and symbols around
me, especially my grandpa,
why did you do that, boy?
You don't have to do that.
That's the only thing
that resonated in my mind
when I was incarcerated.
Why did you do that?
You didn't have to do that.
You wasn't illiterate.
You wasn't stupid.
You had everything you had.
But I made the
choice to be foolish
and made a very
[INAUDIBLE] decision that
cost me almost my entire life.
So when I got incarcerated, I
was sentenced to mandatory life
without no parole,
which means they
wanted me to die in prison.
And I said, I'll
never die in prison.
I'm not going to die in prison.
Just like I walked
in, I'mma walk out.
So thank God I'm here
to share my story,
and I'll never go back--
period.
I'm never going back.
And I want to congratulate
all of these individuals
up here who have to
come to the forefront
and be a prime example of what
attitude and what education
can do for your life.
AARON KINZEL: So I'll
just say really brief,
I'll piggyback off
what Carlos said.
Networking is key.
Again, I put out
hundreds of applications.
I never got a call back.
But when I started making deep
connections and relationships--
like, my boss now,
ironically, is
a judge from Washtenaw County.
He's the director of
criminology and criminal justice
where I work now.
So isn't that the kind
of ironic relationship--
the felon and the judge.
But I have great and deep
respect for this man,
and he's been a
mentor to me, and I've
learned a lot from him.
And he sees in me opportunity
and spark of light.
If there's one thing
I would want to know,
besides the networking,
I would say,
reentry services should start
day one when you get locked up,
not when you come home.
You should be getting
prepared day one.
If you've got a 10-year bid on
your first day in the system,
you should start
to build what you
need to do for reentry
services upon your release,
and I know a lot of people
rarely ever do that.
Secondary to that,
understanding trauma.
Many people who go
into the carceral state
are already traumatized, and
that trauma is never addressed.
A lot of people who are
convicted of felonies
are survivors of crime.
Myself, I was one.
My stepfather tried to murder
me at the age of eight--
and lots of other
abuse and violence
that I was subjected
to, which I'm not
saying that to not be
accountable for my crime,
but it was certainly
a stepping stone that
led me into that direction.
And if we don't address
trauma in the carceral spaces,
like solitary confinement,
being separated from families,
all these different things,
when people come home,
they don't know how
to deal with it.
And I was certainly not
an exception to that rule.
When I first came home, 10
years out of the system,
that Motorola flip
phone was weird.
That's a trauma.
Technology, I get anxious.
I'm nervous.
I feel like I'm stupid
because I don't really
know how to work
technology and others do,
and I just don't know how to
really socially acclimate back
into society.
No one teaches us those skills.
So understanding trauma and
having trauma-informed care
right when you come
into the system
so you can start to address that
trauma so that when you come
home, you're much more safer
and less likely to recidivate
upon release.
JACOB SMITH:
Michelle, do you have
any incite you want to
share about the women
in the program that might--
MICHELLE SMART: So the
women that we service,
our organization is fairly new.
We just launched our
employment initiative
in June of this year, where
we have hired four women.
On average, they serve
over 40 years in prison.
And some of the things that
they have expressed-- actually,
Michelle, I don't
think she minds
me sharing-- that
Michelle Pearson joined
our organization in
September after serving
34 years in prison.
This is her very first
job since coming home.
The ladies have
shared that being
reintegrated in the community
is very important to them.
They want to give back.
They want to be looked
at who they are today.
They're trying to,
again, forget their past.
They want to be accepted.
They want to work.
They want to be recognized as
individuals who have already
paid their dues.
Personally, I've
never been to prison.
I have a family member, a
close friend, whose daughter
is currently incarcerated.
So that's my passion for
helping women upon coming home.
But they have shared
that getting out
and engaged in the community and
getting the support that they
need as far as cell phones,
technology, education--
even simple things as
going to the grocery store.
You've been away 34 years, 40
years, that's overwhelming.
So our organization--
as I said, we
are doing things a
little different.
Our ladies have a health
and wellness coach
who comes in every Wednesday.
They do everything
from yoga to--
they have fitness classes.
We have a conference room
that we call the gym.
So we move things around
to accommodate the ladies.
They have a life coach that
they meet with twice per month,
someone that they can go to.
They don't all
have family members
that they can go to
if they're struggling
or anyone that they can
share their struggles with.
We also work with
a local bank who
has helped them with things like
opening up a savings account.
We want them to know
about budgeting.
So they're coming back
to a whole new world,
and they definitely
need the support.
JACOB SMITH: And just to
hammer the point home--
because this is something
that we touch on
in almost every episode.
The power of networking, I
really can't stress enough.
This is something that almost
every guest on the podcast
touches on in some capacity.
Folks that are successful are
folks that build a network.
People hire people
that they know,
that they're comfortable with.
And one way to do that is by
meeting people and forming
that personal relationship,
so I appreciate that.
And thank you guys
for all that insight.
I also just want to
point out before I forget
to mention that each of
these wonderful panelists
has been featured individually
on the podcast previously
in different capacities
on separate episodes,
deep-diving into their
individual areas of expertise.
So if you're interested
in learning more
about these different stories--
IMANI MIXON:
Thereturningcitizen.org.
JACOB SMITH: --then I strongly
encourage everyone to do that.
What's that?
IMANI MIXON:
Thereturningcitizen.org.
JACOB SMITH: Yeah,
thereturningcitizen.org,
absolutely.
Great, well, moving
right along, so I'd
love to hear from
you guys specific.
We're here at the Google
Detroit headquarters.
What specific opportunities
do you see through technology
specifically?
I know a few of you have
touched on this a little bit.
I do want to point out that
this podcast wouldn't exist
if Erik hadn't been reading
technology magazines in prison
and heard about
podcasting, and this idea
that a radio show could touch
people all over the world.
That was how this
entire thing came about.
Eric was like, I heard
about this really cool thing
called a podcast.
Like, literally, that's
how that started.
So I'm curious to
know, like, what--
this is an example of how
technology can empower folks.
What opportunities do you
see through technology?
And then on the flip side,
what types of challenges
do you see through technology?
AARON KINZEL: So I think
there's a lot of opportunity
for technology.
Something that has been done
as a pilot in the Michigan
Department of Corrections and
other correctional systems
nationwide is they're
starting to integrate tablets
into those carceral
spaces, which I think
is extremely powerful.
And some people
will some kick-back
on that saying that they're
kind of pimping the prisoners,
but I really have
a pushback on that
because they're making money off
these tablets-- which you know,
Google's a corporation, too.
No, I'm not hating on Google.
You guys gotta make money.
It is what it is.
There's a bottom dollar.
You gotta do things.
But what I think is
extremely important
is getting that technology
in those prison spaces
where people are
able to start getting
those technological skill sets.
And something I'm
working on now is
I'm trying to develop a pilot
with the University of Michigan
Dearborn in which we can
create hybrid courses that
will be offered, and we're
looking for foundations
to fund those where
some of the courses
could be held
online in a tablet.
So they could be
getting academic credit
doing a course on a
tablet in their cell,
but also having face-to-face
classes, kind of like we
have here out on the streets.
Because there's a lot
of hybrid functionality.
I don't think we should
have a fully online
or fully in person, but I
think a blend of the two
integrating technology is great.
I'm sorry, the other part?
JACOB SMITH: Challenges.
AARON KINZEL: Challenges--
getting those tablets
into the prison system.
The Department of Corrections
is kind of strange at times.
It's a very strange bird.
So when they feel that
it is to their advantage,
they're more open to it.
And I think what places like
Google and other foundations
that are connected to these
corporate entities can do is
try to develop relationships
with Department
of Corrections-- maybe
the Michigan Department
of Corrections as a start,
other Department of Corrections
at the federal level state--
and find ways to
really give them
opportunities to allow
prisoners to have programming
with these
technological products.
KARLOS L. HARRIS: So in April,
I did a commencement speech
at Lapeer Correctional
Institution
for about 53 individuals
who had gained their GED.
And while there, I was
approached and asked
if there was a way that we
could actually offer training
at this individual prison.
The prison is the
only one in the state
that houses youthful offenders.
And so I actually
proposed to MDOC
that we would be able to
come in and train them
in digital marketing.
Why?
Because it saved my life.
Right?
And so speaking directly about
the technology, the platform
that they use is called
Lantern, and it's with JPay.
The JPay system is the one
that's used statewide in order
that they would receive--
whether it be funding, or
media, videos, trainings.
And the unique thing
about the JPay system
is that if you are a
educational institution,
you can set the
platform up at no cost
to the inmates themselves.
And so that's
something that we've
been working on at the school.
And I would love to
partner with you guys
in order to make
that accessible.
Because one of the
first things that we
were given the
problem of was, how
do we get more of the
guys the trainings
that we have developed?
And it seemed like the
easiest way was through JPay.
And the wheel doesn't
have to be reinvented.
It's just a matter of
putting the content together,
getting it on a system.
And it's amazing
that I've already
developed these
relationships that I'm
able to make that happen.
So what are the
unique challenges
that I see as far
as the technology?
The individuals that
are coming home.
The ones that I sit and I try
to work with on a daily basis,
they just have no
idea whatsoever
of how far this
technology can take them.
Literally.
I have guys that
come home and think
that it's OK to just
post anything on Facebook
until they go out
to an interview,
and they don't get the job
because of what they posted,
right?
I have individuals that
have been returned back
to prison because of
postings that they made.
So they haven't really
got a fine sense
of the technology and the
day and age that we live in.
So I think that that's
one of the haphazards
to the technology piece for
those that are coming on.
ERIK BURGESS: Piggyback
on what Carlos
said, Technology is what
I think is going to keep
most individuals out of prison.
Fortunately, this is
the way of the world.
And we must be prepared
and equipped to be
a part of the world if
we want to be productive.
Network and technology
got me to this point.
When I approached Jacob--
somebody told me
about the podcast.
I was like, how can
I implement this
in my life to make an impact
all around the world--
not only just in Wayne
County or Detroit?
I wanted to make
an impact and share
my story around the world.
So I approached Jacob.
I was like, man, you
heard of a podcast?
I met Jacob at an
event, just talking.
I'm always talking
and asking question,
so it didn't make a difference.
He could have been
four feet tall.
It didn't make a difference.
[LAUGHS]
I was like, Jacob have you
heard of-- introduce myself,
as everybody did, as such and
such, this amount of time.
He was like, I want
to hear your story.
I said, have you of
heard of a podcast?
He said, yes.
So I told him I had an idea,
and we collaborated, and this
is where we are right now.
And I think the biggest
challenge, the biggest obstacle
for improvement is self.
That's what it's based on.
It's based on self.
So the advancement
is based on yourself
if you want to advance.
Where your biggest
challenges is is self.
You've got to want to change.
That's why I want to become--
we've got to want to change.
So self is the biggest
challenge, or self,
is the improvement.
MICHELLE SMART: I'm going
to have to agree with Eric.
It is self.
And I have to be
honest because I'm
kind of technology challenged
myself in certain areas.
We have the ladies coming home.
They're getting
these cell phones.
They have no idea
how to use them.
I mean, I pick mine up.
As long as I can say hello
and send a text, I'm good.
Are the apps and all of that
stuff, I don't personally use,
so we've been trying
to get someone out
to train the ladies on
using the cell phones.
I mean, you don't have to speak
with someone with your cell
phone on speaker,
that type of thing.
And it's been challenging.
They have a certain
carrier that they use,
and just trying to get someone
from that particular carrier
to come out or you know to
help the ladies with that,
it's been quite difficult.
So I'm kind of guilty myself.
I don't know a lot
about the technology,
but I'm learning and
willing to learn.
JACOB SMITH: But you did
launch an e-commerce business,
which is pretty cool.
She doesn't know
about technology
and still launched an
e-commerce business-- testament
to how far technology's come.
So now, what we're going
to do is we're actually--
so as many of the folks tuning
in and the folks in this room
know, Google is a leader in
the training and education
space around the world.
I mean, all types of incredible
programs come out of Google.
So I'm going to invite Elyse
Guilfoyle to come rejoin us up
here and tell us a
bit more in detail
about the types of
relevant efforts
that Google is working on.
And then, we're
going to kick off--
we took some Q and A
in advance, so we're
going to kick off the Q and A
and turn it back to the panel.
ELYSE GUILFOYLE:
Thank you so much.
And thanks everybody
for your perspective
and sharing your experiences.
This has been really incredible.
So some of the
things that Google
has done I think on a
national level-- and Aaron,
you mentioned this earlier.
There's the Ban
the Box initiative.
And in 2016, Google, along with
a lot of other tech companies,
pledged to end up having
a box that says, like,
"have I ever been
convicted of a felony"
very early on in the process
that removes a lot of people
from being considered.
And it doesn't give context
for what they've been through,
and their experience,
and all of their--
and even qualifications.
So I think our question to
you is, in addition to that--
and we have a lot of other
smaller local initiatives
to that are trying to make a
difference for the people who
have been formerly incarcerated,
but I guess what role do you
see companies like Google
and other businesses playing
in ex-offenders'
reentry into society
and, especially, the workforce?
ERIK BURGESS: First
of all, I think
Google can develop
a platform where
it can-- a proactive
process, where it can include
diversity and inclusion.
Myself, I'm working on a
social entrepreneur business
as far as--
it's called Digit 650.
And the reason I
call Digit 650 is
because the way we communicate
in the world is digital.
And 650, I was convicted.
That's my past.
I was convicted under
the 650 drug-lifer law.
So that's why I
call it Digit 650,
where I can make my past
make an imprint on the future
and where my goal is to go
into the juvenile court system
and try to eliminate
FTAs, which FTAs stand
for "failure to appear"
due to the lack of probably
transportation or any
external or internal factors
the parents may have.
75% of Wayne County families
have smartphones, and 60% or so
of families do not
have transportation.
So any low-income defendants
who may have trouble or somehow
impeding transportation
or any other inconvenience
to get to court, my goal is to
have a virtual hearing court
session for nonviolent offenders
or whatever through mobile.
It can be mobile,
iPad, or computer.
Google shouldn't have to put
any money into this system.
If they just have the
willingness to be involved--
companies like that, just the
willingness to be involved.
It's not all about
financial gain.
So it's about willingness
to be involved,
having compassion,
and having a purpose.
So that's why I feel Google
and any other organization that
can help be proactive-- and I'm
looking for reactionary aspect.
Because we have a
lot of reactionary
organizations out here.
But like I say,
my goal is really
to change this title of "The
Returning Citizen Podcast"
and change it to "Not to Become
a Returning Citizen" soon.
KARLOS L. HARRIS: So
if I had a wish list--
I have this thing
where I say we have
to hold their feet to the fire.
Although there's a
lot of propaganda
about returning
citizens and having
second chances, in truth,
that's all that it is at times
is propaganda.
Last year, we graduated
about 185 individuals
through our programs.
And a huge portion of them
were returning citizens.
And at the end of the day,
it's still difficult for us
to find employment
opportunities for them.
I don't care if the Ban the
Box initiative doesn't pass.
Whatever the situation
is, it's the fact
that their background
still follow them.
So if companies like
Google, who have
come into perhaps
one of the cities
within the state where the most
returning citizens are coming
back to, would actually
take up the initiative
to offer some sort
of -level positions
to some of these
offenders, that would
be huge within our community.
As well as if
there was some sort
of incentives behind your
entrepreneur endeavors.
A lot of us are
entrepreneurial-minded.
And if we had an
opportunity to actually find
some sort of funding for
the ideas that we had,
that would be huge
for us as well.
So I think that those pairings
would offer a great opportunity
for those within the community
to accelerate their return
and be more successful.
AARON KINZEL: So I take
it even to a higher level.
I mean, there's a lot of
formerly incarcerated people
that could go well beyond
entry-level position.
So I really
encourage you to look
at people who could be at
the administrative level,
perhaps on a foundation
board, or maybe even create
a panel of formerly
incarcerated people.
If you want to work on
reforming the system
and give back through
corporate donations,
you need a panel of people
that have been justice-involved
and also survivors of crime.
People always leave them
out of the equation.
You need survivors of crime who
are people on the streets that
have been subjected to criminal
activity and also people
that have been in
the carceral state,
and then mix it up with
random other community members
to kind of really find a way--
what are the programs
that are worth funding?
What do you want to
throw your dollars at?
And find some really
bright individuals
who have gained
academic credentials,
professional credentials,
technological credentials that
can really help expand Google
in completely different ways.
And I really challenge Google.
Think about ways how you
can really invest technology
into prisons and jails.
And also, youth facility--
that's another thing we rarely
talk about--
these juvenile detention
facilities nationwide,
where youth are often forgotten.
If anybody deserves
a second chance,
it's someone under the age 18.
Kids should definitely never be
just the snapshot of one thing
that they've done in their life.
MICHELLE SMART: Wow.
Through our
organization, our program
is a nine-month transitional
employment initiative.
We're actually testing
this concept out.
When the ladies
transition out, it
is our thought that they
would either transition out--
Michelle's shaking her head no.
She's already told
me she's going
to be protesting outside
when her nine months is up.
But we don't know
what we don't know.
So we don't know if
nine months is actually
enough time for the ladies
when they come home.
But we do know
that, at some point,
they are going to transition
out of our program,
and we are looking for partners,
someone to partner with us so
ladies will have trained,
they'll have the job skills,
they'll have the life skills.
And at some point, they
will transition out.
We love to partner
with organizations
so that they know that when
they leave our organization,
they have some place to go
as far as being employed.
Or entrepreneurship--
we're working
with Build Institute, who will
be taking some of our ladies
who have
entrepreneurship desires.
They want to start
their own businesses.
So collaborations like that
for us would definitely
be very important.
ELYSE GUILFOYLE:
Awesome, thank you.
Yes, we can maybe do
two more questions.
So last year, we hosted
a Talks at Google event
that featured
RecoveryPark Farms, which
is based here in Detroit.
And I think our
question was around,
have you seen
other organizations
that have had similar
success in building
a bridge for returning
citizens from incarceration
to the workforce?
JACOB SMITH: I'm going to hand
this one over to the panel,
but I just want to
point out that Anna
Kohn from RecoveryPark Farms
was featured on, I believe,
episode 2 of "The
Returning Citizen Podcast."
They are an incredible
organization,
so I'm so excited to hear that.
A major function
of the podcast is
to be highlighting, in
detail, other entities that
are deep diving and
doing this type of work.
But I'd love to not go
into too much detail
and let the panel
answer that one.
AARON KINZEL: I guess I'll
bring it back not necessarily
specifically to the city of
Detroit but just statewide,
where this post-secondary
access to education, I think,
is profound.
I think if any issue is
pivotal to helping people
inside finding private donation
monies to help fund prison
education, I think
it's an investment that
will have an incredible
ROI, return on investment,
where you're going to have
people coming out like myself
and the other
gentlemen on this panel
will spend some
significant amount of time
in the system, where education,
I think, for all of us
has been really key in turning
our life around and becoming
productive-- and not just for
ourselves and our families,
but for those around us.
I mentor youth that
come out of the system.
I mentor men who are older than
me, women who are older than me
that did 20, 30
years and help them
get on that technological
kick or access to education.
So if anything, I would just
say, look at our programs
for bringing education
back in the system.
JACOB SMITH: Any specific
example of organizations?
AARON KINZEL: I know the
Vera Institute of Justice,
which is a huge powerhouse
think tank of criminal justice.
They threw a lot
of private dollars
towards prison education.
And they were one of the ones
that helped push that Pell
Grant pilot that we
currently have here
in the state of Michigan
and others across the US.
MICHELLE SMART: So
our organization
is actually what we believe
is the first organization
to empower formerly incarcerated
women with employment
immediately upon their
return to the community.
And just in speaking
with the ladies,
just knowing that they're coming
home and that they have a job,
they want to be able
to be self-sufficient.
We are doing a lot of
collaborative things
in the community
with organizations.
There's another
organization, Rebel Nell,
that does the graffiti
jewelry with women
with barriers to employment.
But as far as when
they come home
and they know when they leave
those prison gates that they
can come to our organization,
get an interview, and be hired,
it's very-- it's crucial.
KARLOS L. HARRIS: So DSDT,
we're kind of different.
And so a lot of
the men and women
that we train,
because of the lack
of being able to bridge
them with employment,
we've been creative
in hiring them.
So at one time, I think we
were up near 30 individuals
that we had employed
with us around March.
And so that comes
through a lot of funding,
whether it be through
the Department of Labor
and some citywide
initiatives as well.
So I think for us, when we're
showing up at these job fairs--
and at times, we're truly
the only one employer
of the returning citizens,
that says something to me.
I've never heard of Bags to
Butterflies until literally I
saw the flyer.
And I don't know
if it's necessarily
that we work in silos.
It's just that the
information isn't out there.
The only other organization
that I'm akin to is LUCK, Inc.
And LUCK, Inc.
does a lot of work
with returning citizens who've
been away for quite some time.
And so I think that if
we are allowed somehow
to come together and work more
as a team to kind of tackle
what's facing our
community, it'll
be more successful for
all of us in the long run.
JACOB SMITH: And quick shout
out to Carlos and DSDT.
We had a gentleman come to us
this past year who had spent
a long stint in prison,
middle-aged guy,
probably around 60 years old--
he was a former school
superintendent or administrator
of some sort.
So to Aaron's point, not
always entry-level talent.
He had committed a crime later
in life, very smart, very
well-educated guy.
And Carlos gave him
an opportunity to--
I don't know exactly
what he's doing,
but some sort of
administrative work at DSDT
as a form of
transitional employment.
So huge shout out.
Any other organizations that
are jumping out to you, Erik,
offhand that you
to mention quickly?
ERIK BURGESS: LUCK,
Inc. and another one
ran by Keith Bennett
called "Flip the Script."
And also, our family
is an organization.
So all you have to do is ask.
Our family and friends--
a huge organization.
So that's where it starts.
ELYSE GUILFOYLE: Thank you.
Our last question is
a little off topic,
but it's very timely as we
approach the midterm elections.
The question is, what are your
thoughts on states like Florida
putting the removal of
felony disenfranchisement
on the ballot, and how can we
support initiatives like this
to enable ex-felons beyond
education, even if we
don't live in those states?
KARLOS L. HARRIS: Please
let me tackle this one.
Please.
All right, so we're part
of a accreditation process
organization called Council
on Occupational Education.
And so we are slated to
be in Florida the 5th
through the 9th of November.
And I am watching this
election so heavily right now.
Because I'm really
at odds with going
to a state where my
community doesn't even
have the right to vote.
So for me, my trip is
literally in the hangar,
as it's decided whether or not
the right to vote by ex-felons
will be granted once again.
I think that the process that
they've been implementing
over the years is archaic.
I cherish my right to vote.
Now think about this.
I'm the guy whose
driver's license
was suspended for 18 years.
And I had more suspended
license tickets,
and I've been in
jails and prisons,
but yet, at every opportunity
I had to vote, I was there.
And my children,
they're 18 and 20 now.
They vote because their
father was there taking them.
So I don't take lightly the fact
of people being disenfranchised
within my community
because they're not
afforded the right to vote.
I think that it's a right
that we're all entitled to,
regardless of our backgrounds.
And we should be afforded the
opportunity to exercise it.
JACOB SMITH: Anyone else
want to weigh in there?
And I just want to point
out-- so in Michigan, formerly
incarcerated
individuals can vote.
Can you vote while
you're in prison?
Will you explain the climate
in Michigan currently?
AARON KINZEL: So as a pretrial
detainee in a county jail,
you're allowed to vote
if you're not convicted.
Once you are sentenced in
the county jail or you go off
to prison, you cannot
vote in Michigan.
There are two states--
one was Maine, and
I believe the other
is Vermont where you can
actually vote absentee ballot
in a prison setting.
So we've got a 2.3 million
people inside right now.
That's a huge voting block.
And now if you take that
and you look at nationally--
there's different
stats that say this--
but roughly 70 million
Americans have some type
of criminal justice history--
whether that's an arrest,
a conviction, a
juvie bit, whatever.
They have something.
So think about that
as a voting block.
So to piggyback off
what Carlos said,
I'm actually
working on something
with the Soros Justice
Fellowship Project,
where I'm trying to create this
carceral state public policy
training academy which
would empower formerly
incarcerated people,
survivors of crime,
not only to register to vote
and vote, but to educate them.
Because a lot of people
who go out and vote
are uneducated
voters, unfortunately.
That's just the reality.
So create a platform that
is criminal justice minded.
What are the important issues?
Like, for instance,
mandatory minimum,
solitary confinement,
abolishing the death penalty,
et cetera, et cetera.
Create a voting block that
is focused on these issues.
Secondary to that,
we need to have
people mobilize in
their communities
and have formerly incarcerated
people and survivors of crime
run for elected offices.
It seems real simple, but a lot
of people are scared to do it.
Local, state, and
federal level, if you
add those 70 million people in
this country, and their family,
and friends, that's half
of this country now.
Think about the
changes that we could
have if we got all those people,
or even just 10% or 20% of them
that could really dramatically
change not just this midterm
election, but come 2020,
I know a certain person
I want to vote the hell out
of office very, very much.
And there's a lot of other
congressional reps, too,
and state level,
and local level.
Because they are
not representative
of a lot of our interests.
I find that, now, we
have corporate policy.
And no offense to
Google right here,
but I feel that we need
to find more ways that
are more beneficial to citizens
as opposed to corporations,
so that's my platform on that.
JACOB SMITH: And just to clarify
for anyone who is formerly
incarcerated or the families
of folks that are formerly
incarcerated, you
can vote in Michigan
if you're formerly
incarcerated-- so just to be
super clear on that topic.
I think a lot of folks are
intimidated, or confused,
and don't realize that
they are able to vote.
AARON KINZEL: They think
it doesn't matter as well.
They think they're
vote doesn't matter.
JACOB SMITH: They think
their vote doesn't matter.
So, yeah, please,
everybody vote.
ELYSE GUILFOYLE: Great.
Thank you everybody so
much for being here.
A round of applause
for our panel.
[APPLAUSE]
Awesome.
Thank you so much for your time.
We're really glad that you came
here today to share with us.